what if i told you an 86 year old
hungarian-american psychologist could
help you understand how to feel as happy
as possible from playing games
let me explain
earlier this year i got really into
playing tetris effect and while i was
playing it i had a strange but familiar
feeling it felt like i was totally in
the zone
hours went by in moments it was
somewhere between a sense of intense
focus and total relaxation despite how
intense tetris effect gets there was
something calming about playing it not
only that but afterwards it left me with
a long lasting satisfaction that i don't
usually get from playing games
in psychology terms this feeling is
known as flow we've all experienced this
sense of flow or feeling in the zone
while playing games and whether you
realize it or not that's probably when
you enjoy playing games the most and get
the most satisfaction from playing them
the idea of flow was defined by the work
of mihai chick sent me high the 86 year
old hungarian-american psychologist i
mentioned earlier his branch of
psychology is what's known as positive
psychology seeking to understand the
components to a happy life here he is
giving a ted talk about his research
called the secret to happiness i try to
understand now
where
in everyday life in our
normal experience
do we do we feel really happy since
understanding flow is supposedly the key
to happiness i got in touch with
alexander chris to help me get my head
around it he's a clinical psychologist
and author of the gaming mind a book
that looks at why we play games and the
positive impact that games can have on
the psychology of those who play them
flow is
the state of feeling totally immersed
in
a meaningful activity there's often a
sense of a subjective distortion of time
really feeling kind of lost in in the
activity suddenly realizing three hours
have passed and feeling kind of good
about what's that that's happened it's
usually accompanied by a kind of
pleasurable peaceful emotional state it
kind of paints a more organic peaceful
picture of what it means to sort of be
happy or sort of seek happiness chick
sent me high proposed that rather than
money or material possessions it was
through having more flow in their lives
that people found greater happiness
almost any activity can evoke flow but
those that do evoke flowing people tend
to exhibit some but not necessarily all
of these main characteristics that last
point that the activity slightly exceeds
our skill level seems to be a crucial
component
whenever you see writing on flow you
might spot a version of this graph
showing that flow occurs when both the
level of challenge and the skill
required for success are high
in his book finding flow chick sent me
high says games like chess tennis or
poker present easy opportunities for
flow states to occur because games have
goals and rules for action which make it
possible for the player to act without
questioning what should be done and how
it's easy to see that this can just as
easily be applied to many video games
are
activities that
seek to immerse players in a way that
really engages them and in some ways can
kind of take them out of the objectives
time and space outside of the game you
know in general this is this interactive
medium that involves a lot of ongoing
sometimes repetitive actions but but
also progressive actions right sort of
moving forward accomplishing things
getting better developing skills so all
these things potentially can be
meaningful to a player and therefore be
part of what induces a flow state the
interesting thing is that the games that
can put players into a state of flow
seem to vary wildly from person to
person and to prove this i got some of
my friends here at gamespot to talk
about the games that give them a feeling
of flow if there was one game that i can
guarantee would put me into a flow
almost trance-like state that game would
be doom
eternal mega man um dark souls
battlefield to an extent escape from
tacos
overwatch super monkey ball when it
comes to fighting games it's just you
and the other person and that's where
i've experienced being in the zone where
every combo is hitting every frame trap
is working out it is so intense to a
point where the game itself feels like a
blur it's all i can focus on it's all i
can think about and that carries you
forward and keeps you in the zone for
one of a better phrase so i'm completely
in the zone focusing on what's happening
you kind of feel like you sink into
yourself and sort of really feeling that
sort of relaxed vibe that the game has
that can easily just tip over into pure
terror all the action and shooting is
maintaining one portion of my brain
while the strategy is sort of occupying
the other like i'm turning my brain off
but i'm not i'm just so comfortable with
what i'm doing in the game that it's
just second nature at that point the
character is doing exactly just like
what you want it to do and the
controller and then the game is an
extension of yourself and it feels
amazing not think so much and just be in
the zone for what i'm doing my brain
really doesn't have space
for much else and i'm just rolling
around in the ball thinking about
rolling around in the ball you just
can't stop playing so how can it be that
games as varied as tetris effect super
monkey ball and doom eternal can produce
the same psychological effect
in different players well it won't
surprise you to know that many video
game developers have used research into
flow to help shape their games and maybe
the most obvious application of this
theory in a game
is flow
back in the mid-noughties genova chen
who you may know as the founder of that
game company and the director of journey
was a masters student at the university
of southern california's interactive
media and games division chen was
influenced by chick sent me high's
research and wanted to examine how games
could better maintain a player's sense
of flow because flow states require a
delicate balance of challenge and skill
and because players skill levels vary
greatly chen suggested that games could
offer subtle choices to the player to
allow them to essentially customize the
difficulty of the game in order to
subconsciously maintain a state of flow
chen referred to this as dynamic
difficulty adjustment and designed a
game called flow as part of his master's
thesis to demonstrate it flow offers
players a simplistic form of dynamic
difficulty as a primitive cellular life
form players feed on other organisms and
can through eating blue or red nodes
swim deeper to tackle bigger creatures
or back towards the surface to recover
the idea is that by factoring in a kind
of fluid difficulty adjustment within
the game's mechanics the player has
complete control over how challenging
the game is for them at any given moment
this was not a completely new idea to
games though it's not often completely
under the player's control resident evil
4 has a hidden dynamic difficulty
mechanic which will change the frequency
and behaviors of enemies dependent on
the player's skill and left 4 dead and
its sequel have an ai director who
dictates the rates at which certain
enemies weapons or health items spawn
depending on how well players are
performing less subtle examples also
exist mario kart's infamous rubber
banding system springs to mind however
many of these mechanics are designed to
prevent a game from becoming too easy or
too difficult for a player whereas chen
wanted to design a system to ensure
games sustain a sense of fun in his
thesis chen specifically outlines that
being in a flow state shares all the
characteristics of having fun the sense
of timelessness of being at one of
exhilaration focus and immediacy that if
a game evokes a flow experience it will
make the player lose track of time and
self-consciousness chen theorized that
if psychologists are studying the
science behind how to make people happy
it makes sense to apply that knowledge
when making games now whether or not you
think flow itself is successful at
maintaining a sense of fun the truth is
that genova chen is not the only
developer to figure this out in fact
plenty of modern games use a pursuit of
flow as a core tenet of their design in
an interview with noclip doom eternal's
game director hugo martin discusses in
detail the way the game offers challenge
and feedback to ensure players remain in
the fun zone while playing forcing them
to play in a certain style that requires
a flow-like mastery of the game's
mechanics in order to succeed
particularly on nightmare mode which
martin describes as the best version of
the game you know the fun zone is
managing resources it's doing all these
different things it's thinking
constantly it's using the right tool for
the job all these different things and
when they don't play that way
we kill them so is there a way to ensure
that every single time you sit down to
play a game you instantly enter a flow
state play for hours and leave feeling
satisfied
sadly it's probably not as simple as
that there might be something to the
idea that if you want to achieve flow
more often you should push yourself to
play more demanding games games whose
challenge slightly exceeds your skill
level as in the graph in reality however
it's very individual some may find flow
through completing chores in animal
crossing but find dark souls tedious as
chick sent me high himself says nobody
can tell you how to reach happiness
except yourself there's some degree of
mystery to this process still it's not
just a switch that flips on right where
you sit down and you're like enter this
state a lot of it has to do with the
players participation right they have to
really let themselves get into what
they're doing the thing that popped into
my mind is you know a few months ago i
was playing hades on the switch and
that's a game that has like no loading
times right and so which we should like
has to because it's so about dying and
being reborn like if it didn't move
quick it would stop being this sort of
constant movement so in that sweet spot
and it would become this sort of it does
it doesn't feel worth it and i think it
would rip you out of that state perhaps
a better idea is to find a game that you
enjoy that keeps you in the game as much
as possible and allows you to keep
playing for as long as possible
features like near instant loading times
and quick resume on newer consoles could
make this easier than ever many of the
games in which people experience flow
states while playing have an element of
never ending flow to their gameplay and
a constantly adapting goal be it newly
opened areas to explore are high score
to beat or multiplayer games that offer
thousands of new opponents to compete
with tetris is an obvious example of a
never-ending game in her book reality is
broken writer and game developer jane
mcgonagall sums it up perfectly saying
what makes tetris so addictive despite
the impossibility of winning is the
intensity of the feedback it provides it
only gets harder when you're playing
well creating a perfect balance between
hard challenge and achievability many
gamers would rather keep playing than
win thereby ending the game in high
feedback games the state of being
intensely engaged may ultimately be more
pleasurable than even the satisfaction
of winning the standout
example or series for me is the
civilization series right which i've
always been a fan of famously when you
win civilization it shows you the
victory screen and then there's a little
button that says just one more turn
right there like there is this awareness
that even though like the game is over
maybe you just kind of want to keep
going with it right this this sense that
that actually really is so much of the
experience it is not just the outcome of
victory but the the flow of play perhaps
this is why we love video games so much
they offer a potentially never ending
resource of a state of being that some
very clever people believe is the key to
a happy life it's enough to set alarm
bells ringing for reactionary
technophobe parents the world over the
bottom line is that according to chick
sent me high at least the more flow
people have in their lives the happier
their lives will be
chances are you already know the games
that give you that feeling but if not
you'll have to discover for yourself
what games can put you in a state of
flow let me know in the comments down
below what they are thanks again to
alexander chris for his involvement in
this video i've left a link to his book
and all the other books and videos that
i looked at during my research in the
description below you can also see a
video that i made a few months back
about dark souls and mental health in
the meantime leave a like and hit
subscribe if you've enjoyed the video so
that we can keep making content like
this thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you